european union environment ministers
have exchanged views on new rules to
monitor
report on and check carbon dioxide
emissions from maritime transport
the ministers weighed whether the
proposals to harmonise surveillance of
the main gas
responsible for global warming are
balanced and flexible enough
and do not impose a heavy administrative
burden
co2 emissions represent about 98
of the greenhouse gases emitted by ships
it's hoped that the eu model will serve
as an example
for the creation of a global system
the ministers also welcomed new
proposals to stop the spread of
introduced
animal and plant species into the eu
which are causing severe damage to the
environment
invasive alien species are transported
outside their normal habitat through
human action
this can hurt the new ecosystem and have
serious economic and social consequences
around twelve 000 alien species are
thought to be found in europe
about 10 to 15 percent of them have
spread and are costing the eu at least
12 billion euros
each year the new measures would involve
a prevention plan
an early warning and rapid response
system plus steps to manage the species
as they spread